you know what you told me that we were
bringing my family into my like would
you rather because I feel like you can
tell a lot by people's choices I feel
like I have to thank everything through
and like make sure I'm making the right
decision as if it's going to happen in
real life ah one pole you're done
but jabbing the toothpick and then
kicking something it's just insult to
injury I feel like honestly my big toe
is so sensitive if I hit anything with
it it's like I go crazy I'm gonna go
with the second one because it doesn't
say how hard it kicked my foot it
who
are there laws against having sex with
the goat well if we're saying that sex
is a very loose definition then I'll say
that I will have sex with the goat and
no one will know
I'd much rather live with people
thinking something about me and me
knowing the truth then having done
something that feels awful y'all can go
ahead and think I had sex of a goat but
I don't want to actually have how would
I have this gate sex oh definitely
vaginas forgets that's an easy one that
would be inconvenient vagina ears 100% I
just wear your moves all the time I got
ten fingers and I don't want ten dicks
I'm like Edwards penis hands or
something like that like I couldn't like
touch anyone who would want to love me
what's life as a potato really I don't
want to be a potato in a past life I
certainly was already a potato so I
don't think this question applies to me
I would go with eat a potato and then I
would just stop eating potatoes no my
babies watch these videos but by process
of elimination I'm not doing the first
one so I'm doing second I feel like
that's like a commitment of have the
washing every single day in my life so
um it's gonna be a very passive third
wheel in the threesome I'm not gonna
answer it I can't answer that I'll
figure it out but I do not want to my
parents I don't that's not gonna happen
I need a mouthwash question for that
question I'd rather just jump off a
building than do any of those things
how do you think of these things these
questions are crazy but very good it's
okay but it's not okay the potato thing
made me think a lot you know I don't
think being a potato would be that bad
I really don't
Oh